[Applause]
[Music]
happy
wednesday
everyone so it turns out there are only
two sexual orientations
leftists and everyone else
it's true according to a new poll 71
percent of democrat college students
wouldn't go on a date with someone with
opposing views versus only 31 percent of
republicans that's a difference of like
a thousand percent cat
yeah although 40 percent of young dems
refused to be friends with the other
side compared to just five percent of
republicans so apparently the newly woke
prefer to judge you as good or evil
based on political affiliation which can
explain how a child rapist rioter
attacking someone in kenosha suddenly
became a martyr
also thirty percent of dems but only
seven percent of republicans wouldn't
work for someone who voted differently
from them which sucks for democrats
since all bosses are republicans
[Laughter]
but on the bright side democrats
everyone at the unemployment office they
vote blue
gender affects the divide and that fewer
women would go on a date with someone
who voted for an opposing candidate than
men probably because men don't see
politics when they see hotness
meaning if a guy has sex with a woman
who looks like a young bridget bartow
and suddenly notices her obama tattoo
i'm pretty sure that won't be a deal
breaker
fact is if we saw politics before looks
politics wouldn't exist because neither
would we
the study also shows fewer women would
shop at a business owned by someone of
the other party although i'm sure that
changes when there's a shoe sale am i
right cat
hey oh yeah
because chicks like shoes
they can't you know they'll throw it
they'll just go buy shoes you got me
they got it they buy shoes you got it
all right shut up
so the partisan divide is real but it's
as one-sided as the french-made apron i
wear at stuart varney's place
[Laughter]
axios who did the polling conclude such
a divide makes future discord all the
more likely i mean you gotta wonder how
far a liberal might take this
good morning mr farrell you are a very
lucky man we found a donor for your
transplant
wait a minute whose kidney is that
well we don't know but he did say the
donation was part of being a good
american
oh a conservative's kidney i'd rather
die
without this kidney you will die look
you don't understand he had hate in his
heart and it's probably in his kidneys
too
i don't
i don't need a bigoted organs
yeah they're applauding the death of
gene
i'm with you
so the this divide isn't the real story
it's really why these spoiled brats can
no longer recognize that other
perspectives have value instead it just
means you're evil so if you're for low
taxes you're an evil greedy person if
you're for strong law enforcement you
must hate minorities if you want school
choice you must be a domestic terrorist
all of these beliefs however are not
original they are dispersed by the
triple t-shirt cannon that is the media
academia and the arts they're the super
soakers of bad ideas and there's nothing
unique or rebellious about them and once
again we find that tolerance as
practiced by the left is as real as
cat's hair
it's not tolerance if you tolerate only
those who accept your beliefs it's just
like how anti-racist really means racist
so where does this new hate actually
come from it's not like it simply erupts
in the brains exactly at the same age
for everyone it's not like puberty where
you suddenly get aroused by the legs of
an ottoman
and by you i mean me
or like cat where she suddenly suddenly
her voice is deeper than james earl
jones yeah
nope hate is assigned to you like a
social security number from somewhere
else think about it all those deranged
political kids used to be okay they were
part of loving families at some point
buffy was a decent fun-loving
open-minded kid who played well with
others and then one day like a remake of
invasion of the body snatchers that
spirit of fun and cooperation got
replaced by robotic rage the kid comes
home infused with anger and their
youthful good looks deliberately defaced
like the side of a graffiti-covered
train sitting on the tracks the cheap
piercings the horribly dyed shaved hair
the ugliness is the work uniform for the
unemployable if you don't know what i
mean just google anti-fog mug shots or
go to the supercuts website
so the transformation is no product of
some biochemical change it's so
conforming that it tells you it's a
well-packaged ideological virus designed
to pit human against human the shia and
the sunnis have nothing on us that's
wokism which relies only on one single
variable identity this dark spiteful
movement is given a wide berth because
normal people are terrified of them it's
like being berated by a homeless guy
high on bath salts it's better to
appease than become a target of a mostly
peaceful protest but beneath these
superficial changes lurks a dark fascism
that's fed daily on campus by elites who
decide the best way to get revenge
against a country they despise is to
poison impressionable minds and then
release them into the wild it's not that
they won't want to work for you or don't
want to date you they want you destroyed
they want to cancel you your business
your bank account your right to free
speech it's what brought us antifa and
the riots being politically apart to
them means the same thing it does to a
serial killer who has you tied to a
radiator in his basement they can do
anything to you and they will they're
not robbing expensive handbags they're
punching hitler by stealing expensive
handbags
so maybe it's time for a national
intervention back in the eras of cult
cults we called it deprogramming and
today this is a cult and like a cult
they take impressionable people and
isolate them from any family or friends
that hold a different view to take
advantage of them so where do they go
after college when they can't date
converse or work with half the
population and their only skills are
painting crude signs and making a decent
molotov cocktail
they become more and more reliant on the
cult or they get a job at cnn
[Applause]
welcome tonight's yes
jim acosta sends her his therapy bills
former white house press secretary
co-host of outnumbered and author of the
new book for such a time as this
haley macadeny
he represented oklahoma
better than a tornado lifted up a cow
ceo ceo of chickasaw bank and former
speaker the house in oklahoma t.w
shannon
he's the top comic in alaska which
explains why his career is on ice
comedian writer and actor jamie lassau
and you can find her in manhattan's
finest restaurants stealing waiters tips
foxy's contributor captive
gayley mac and amy before i get to the
topic congratulations on your new book
uh though i do have a question for this
uh i can tell pink is your favorite
color right yes it is very pink there
you go this is like it's like a baby
shower
um
for such a time as this what does that
mean
hey it's from the bible you said you
thought it was from a song i think right
during break but it's from the bible
so right now esther t.w
and kaylee are bible shaming me we are
i'm in bible shape i read the bible but
i was like seven
greg this is the point where you tell
your audience look under your chairs
[Laughter]
i'm afraid of what they'll find
out here
anyway so kaylee um
are you surprised by this discrepancy
that republicans like republicans have
always been uh portrayed as
narrow-minded and yet we're willing to
date anybody yeah i'm so proud of my
republicans we'll date across the aisle
we'll work across the aisle we'll have
friends across the aisle and the liberal
women are the ones driving all the hate
but hey i have a theory on this i think
for the left for a lot on the left
politics is their religion yeah so
therefore they take this uber personally
and also you hit the nail on the head
mentioning universities these i've been
on three of them they are bastions of
just self-reinforcing your own ideas if
you're a conservative your hyde if
you're a liberal you're just reinforced
and you become this hater big time
because you think there's only one way
to think well and uh before i move on i
mean you when you were on cnn you were
surviving and living outside the
conservative bubble so like you have
every authority in right to crap on
these people because you every day
had to you were like that you were the
pin cushion hey i was hiding behind
doors from the menacing liberals i
thought they'd pushed me off the set at
one point yeah yeah your heart broken
over chris cuomo oh yes
all right jamie welcome back to the
united states
i'm kidding
would you date someone who voted
differently than you
oh sure and by the way i wasn't up on
the bible stuff either really like if i
had read the bible after today i would
have thought they got it from that book
i don't know what it is about the vibe
no more bible stuff you know the part
where they're like oh there's a gospel
according to mark i always wondered is
that sarcastic like oh this is the
gospel
according to mark i just don't know what
i'm sorry greg
you are going to get angry letters
from me
as a fiercely religious person okay what
are your thoughts on i i live in alaska
i just want a letter from anybody
[Laughter]
greg i would absolutely when i read this
article like young dems are being so
picky they want to be the perfect
political party how nice to have options
yes
how nice i would date a girl from the
republican party the democratic party of
the a bachelorette party a slumber party
i'm 47 i'm 47 in divorce i would date a
girl from the communist party i just
don't want to die alone
i just don't want to die alone
it's i'm in a weird spot because i was
married for you know i was married for
16 years right and um then you got to go
back into the dating pool which is not
easy and i had a friend of mine go dude
i'm excited for you like you're not that
old he said these exact words i never
heard this before he goes you're going
to be able to get out there and get some
strange he said yes
which did sound kind of exciting because
to tell you guys like the god's honest
truth
i wasn't even getting any familiar
[Laughter]
oh that was a nice little journey into
the tortured brain jaime lists out t.w
the bottom line is i cannot follow that
you know what i think i think kaylee
hits on it which is that it's not it's
not just left and right it's the people
who take their politics so seriously
that it is personal and it makes
forgiveness
like or a tolerance or forgiveness uh
just impossible yeah but we shouldn't be
surprised as kaylee mentioned that it
starts in college but it starts way
early in that the left starts this
indoctrination this is what that
critical race theory is all about where
they start this hatred at a very very
early age and they've launched a war
against the three c's that made this
country great right it's capitalism it's
christianity and it's the constitution
that's what built this country and made
it great you left out carbs and
carbohydrates of course
but that's what that's what's you know
that's really been the foundation of
this country and the left they're
attacking it on every front when you
read the headlines just look again every
single time it's those three pillars
that they're going after and this is
just another great example of that they
hate they hate what this country stands
for and they tell the kids very early
that you know and by the way they're
very tolerant of every other religion
they're very tolerant of every other
economic system they're very tolerant
every other governmental system except
for those three when it comes to that
it's all out war and we see it happening
right now and it's become part of the
culture war and now you've got big tech
who's part of it i mean it is it is a
scary time for young people so i'm not
surprised because the hate star is very
early the other c is chick-fil-a
yeah that's true that's why you know
that if you want to that's the lord's
chicken yeah and also it's like even
leftists that's like they're going i'm
not going to date anybody but
their stomach wants chick-fil-a so
they'll just suspend all ideology to eat
there kat
did you my point being that these things
are assigned to people right do you like
you know somebody that's been
radicalized it's so obvious that somehow
it was assigned to them externally
nobody comes to these weird conclusions
just
you know one minute they're nice then
they come back and they're all
[Applause]
i have experienced that
because it's easier probably than doing
your own thinking
but obviously none of this could apply
to me because you know if i only dated
people that you know agreed with my
political views i would have never been
able to date anyone and we all know
that's not true
i have limits there was this one guy
that um he on our first date though he
said that we should do speech in this
country the way that they do it in china
and that was a i i that was my bit much
for me like i only saw him four times
after that
you mean he was against freedom of
speech yeah but that's all because i was
such an open-minded person i was willing
to give it a chance it had nothing to do
with my tragic attraction to neck
tattoos yes well there's you know the
thing is you're the only person that
repeatedly dates people with neck
tattoos but maybe there's been a few but
not like you make us like it's a lot one
is too many cat how about four
don't you think that freedom of speech
when he's bringing up he was just
applying it to you
oh because he don't want me to talk i
mean that's probably also true but i
didn't have that i wasn't that
interested in what he had to say either
there you go it was the next tattoo you
were after yes greg if i had a neck
tattoo it would say um i didn't get the
job did i
[Laughter]
perfect
way to button it up champ hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else